let's go from Massachusetts to New York
we're going to take our next caller from
the 917 area code caller what's your
name where you calling from and what's
on your mind hey David my name is James
I'm calling from New York City what's on
my mind I guess is just hair integrity
the you mentioned in your car post that
it was a talking about your hair would
be irrelevant but as far as Donald Trump
goes right oh that's very much like a
second he doesn't yeah yeah this is
crazy like if you look at it it's just
like uncanny like an uncanny valley sort
of and I wonder why it none of his
supporters even try to defend his hair
and just wondering if you have any
thoughts on Inauguration Day maybe the
wind will be really bad well i think i'm
counting on i'm founder we're on the
wind being so bad that we see Donald
Trump's hair do things we've never seen
hair do before like there's a ninety
percent chance of around essay and I
don't think he's going to be able to
hide behind one of those make America
great again hat yeah we've been watching
the forecast for today for a while
actually wear a wig I yeah that's true
he could and I guess now they wouldn't
even know the difference yeah uh yeah
well listen I'm glad that got here are
two important topics here and I do
believe that Donald Trevor hair will be
playing a role today in the inauguration
proceedings that I think we can all rest
assured about thank you so much for the
club always go to hear from New York
City Wow hearing from a lot of Davis to
be really good work thank you my
pleasure